THE HOME WHITE CONTROLLED BY
COLORADO.
SNAPPS IS BROUGHT
TO YOU BY TACO BELL.
THEY'LL BE ROLLING ALONG THE TOG
A SHOT.
IT WAS FROM THE DEFENSEMAN WHO
HAD SNUCK UP AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE AS
HE
GREAT CHANCE FOR THE 19-YEAR-OLD
EARLY ON.
SHOT FROM THE POINT F DURZI MAD.
FREE FOR A MOMENT
FINALLY FROZEN BY DARCY GOING TS
TO THE FRONT OF THE NET.
TRYING TO MAKE A PLOW BEFORE
KEMPE WENT DOWN. BY
DANAULT WILL PAD OF
THE SKILL.
A GREAT CHANCE THE NET.
AND COLORADO HAS
AVALANCHE.
AND THE AVS' POWER PLAY GOAL
GETS THEM CAN'T HELP ANYONE ELS.
AGOOD CHANCE TO SCORE, L.A.
RAY: I AM CURIOUS IF THE
AVALANCHE CAN FIND
AND A GREAT CHANCE FOR HIS FIRST
NHL LOOK -- HE COVERS
KIEFERHE'S GOT HIS SEVENTH GOALS
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE CAREER.
TO PEPPER KUEMPER
IT IS GOING TO   BROWN.
STOPPED BY TROPHY -- FLOPPY
FOR COLORADO.
AND KOPITAR ON THE
NI OFF THE
ICE.
HE ROCKET THIS IS
SEAN: WE'RE UNDER NINE MINUTES
TO GO.
COLORADO WITH 1:35 TOIGHTS HEREN
SOUTHE